et bonjour à tous exceptionnellement et
en raison de l'importance de l'actualité
et de la gravité des événements vous me
retrouvais donc en studio pas de samedi
chez vous aujourd'hui
il devait avoir lieu porte de la
chapelle avec frédéric fajardie auteur
de romans policiers
nous le retrouvons samedi prochain 13
décembre mais d'ores et déjà nous le
remercions de sa compréhension
l'actualité prime tout donc un jeune
homme de 22 ans malek oussékine
étudiants à dauphine est mort cette nuit
rue monsieur le prince à paris le
mouvement de protestation des étudiants
et des lycéens de france a tourné au
drame
68 et 86 qui pourtant ne se ressemblent
pas on donc aujourd'hui un point commun
ce la mort plusieurs témoins ont vu la
scène dramatique et met en cause le
comportement de la police la nuit
terrible du quartier latin par nicolas
jacobs patrick voix et françois corner
ce sont ces brigades motorisées de la
préfecture de police le peloton
voltigeurs motocyclistes chargé de
nettoyer les rues qui est ce matin mise
encore sur chaque moto en majorité tout
terrain capable de se faufiler partout
et de grains fait facilement sur les
trottoirs deux hommes l'un pilote
l'eau est armé d'une matraque l'objectif
de l'unité commandée par l'officier de
police et de surprendre d'intervenir
très vite dans un quartier contre les
casseurs et d'impressionner le plus
possible de l'adversaire pour le
déstabiliser
en principe les petits commandos isoler
d'étudiants ont plus souvent de pause
étudiants ne se prête pas ce genre
d'unité évite l'affrontement direct avec
cette brigade très impressionnante et
très mobile dans le feu de l'action il
ya malheureusement parfois des bavures
des claques ou des coups de matraque qui
pleuvent sur des gens qui n'ont souvent
rien à voir avec les casseurs que s'est
il passé la nuit dernière rue monsieur
le prince dans le 6e arrondissement
un groupe de manifestants repliaient sur
le quartier latin après l'évacuation
dans le calme de la sorbonne par les
portes de l'ordre dressent des
barricades et incendient les voitures à
l'angle de la rue de mollir a aidé à rue
monsieur le prince
une patrouille motorisée intervient pour
dégager la rue c'est au moment de cette
intervention qu'un jeune homme de 22 ans
malik oussékine étudiants dauphine est
né à versailles d'approuver la mort
malgré les efforts des sauveteurs pour
le réanimer
arrêt cardiaque consécutive aux coups
portés par les policiers arrêt cardiaque
dû à la peur une enquête est ouverte par
l'inspection générale des polices la
police des polices pour déterminer les
circonstances exactes du décès de ce
jeune étudiant
mais pour l'instant les témoignages sont
accablants ce matin avec le recul un
témoin je suis foutu au balcon puis là
j'ai vu un gros de troupes de crs qui
descendait la rue sur les manifestants
qui se sont tirés dans la rue la foule
qui les crs sont restés tels que
secondes et puis on continue à les
poursuivre et à ce moment là quelques
secondes après encore j'ai vu trois crs
sortir de cet immeuble avec un mec
qu'ils ont littéralement tabassés de
façon extrêmement violente extrêmement
violente au milieu au milieu au nez de
tout et de tout le monde
puis à ce moment là je suis descendu et
puis quand je suis redescendu j'ai revu
encore les crs qui ne prenait pas le
revers du col qui l'ont balancé sur 3 m
le mec s'est remis de ses émotions
et le plus triste date dans c'est qu'il
s'est redirigée vers l'immeuble où il a
été sorti et à composer le code ce qui
est indiqué que c'est un résident et les
crs sont restés dix minutes sur place et
tous les étudiants étaient planqués dans
les immeubles et à côté et il était
vraiment tapi derrière cette grille et
envoyait manifestement que j'avais
vraiment la trouille
et une fois que les crs ont pâti de son
parti ne pensait qu'à porter secours aux
mecs
le samu est arrivé on a vu les pompiers
qui étaient complètement affolée regard
de la victime a été transportée à
l'hôpital cochin il ne sera certainement
pas compliqué de savoir s'il est normal
y coup c'est qu'il a reçu des coups mais
pour l'instant les médecins du samu qui
sont intervenus sur place ces replis
derrière le secret professionnel
bien sûr les considérer comme des
conditions de l'accident de l'incidence
de la maladie sont à prendre en compte
pour savoir l'évolution de la maladie
mais de toute façon dans ce cas là comme
joli du tout à l'heure il ya information
judiciaire je ne peux répondre à vos
questions
nous avons pris en charge un patient qui
avait besoin de besoin nous l'avons
conduit à l'hôpital cochin
tout pourtant avait été prévu la nuit
dernière pour éviter ce genre
d'incidents violents
la sorbonne avait été évacué en douceur
en souplesse par les crs les occupants
n'avaient pas tous des allures
d'étudiant lit d'ailleurs de casseurs
tout avait été prévu sauf ce qui a
peut-être été un dérapage mais le
dérapage est malheureusement souvent
imprévisible
malek boutih